ich bin auf der größten foodmesse der
Welt und ich schnorre mir alle Zutaten
für einen schönen Burger zusammen die
Brötchen habe ich schon mal Martins
potato rolls das Beste vom Besten wir
probieren Ketchup zu bekommen ja we can
take one okay thank you so much Ketchup
wir wollen so ein richtigen billigen
Schmelzkäse die kannst du mitnehmen echt
sehr gut wir haben Käse danke dir mein
lieber okay hinter uns gibt's Senf wir
haben Senf geil wir brauchen jetzt noch
Rindfleisch für unser Paty wir fragen
einfach mal oh mein Gott es klappt
wirklich oh herlich danke dir vielmals
jetzt haben wir alles was wir für ein
geilen Burger brauchen und den machen
wir jetzt hier ist unsere Ausbeute sen
Ketchup cheese beef und BNS fertig
gewolft wir formen jetzt vier gleich
große Kugeln so jetzt toasten wir unsere
BNS an jetzt lassen wir die Pfanne schön
heiß werden geben schon mal ein bisschen
Senf und Ketchup auf unsere BNS und dann
let's go Burger smashen bisschen Salz
und bisschen Pfeffer Käse drauf und ab
auf unsere Burger die Küche steht in
Rauch und unser Burger ist fertig
probieren wir wow knusprig fluffig geil
und die maenspann zerstören alles